[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut à toutes et à tous et bienvenue à
dans culture thé vous savez culture tc
toutes les deux semaines
une ville de france que l'on découvre à
travers ses artistes
cette semaine c'est pas une ville que je
vous propose mais tout simplement le
monde entier enfin on va essayer avec
ces artistes connus reconnus bien au
delà nos frontières tout de suite
le sommaire de votre émission
l'incontournable dessus culture tc bob
sinclar le budget est synonyme de fête
de bonne humeur il est réputé et reconnu
dans le monde entier nous sommes allés à
sa rencontre pour la sortie de son
nouvel album
xavier de maistre harpiste mondialement
connue à il passe son temps et vit à
l'étranger
il est revenu quelques jours en france
pour des représentations
on a eu la chance de le rencontrer
tahiti 80 le groupe de pop fait des
ravages au japon mais un petit peu moins
en france nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre lors d'un concert à la cigale
mais tout de suite c'est l'édito de
votre émission nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de tintin tintin le tatoueur
ils ont fait exactement la même où pète
tintin à et reconnu qu'une nombreuses
années pour son art du tatouage il a su
renouveler tatouage nous explique tout
ça il signe tout simplement
l'édito de cette émission
[Musique]
c'est le plaisir j'ai aujourd'hui encore
acteur ça c'est une belle question eh
ben ce plaisir-là des jolis dessins
comme un enfant quel plaisir il a décidé
voilà quand on aime faire des dessins ou
de la peinture voilà moi mon médium
c'est le tatouage et j'ai ce plaisir-là
forte heureusement tous les matins être
content de venir travailler
j'aime bien faire des tatouages en fait
dès que j'ai vu un joli tatouage
confierait j'ai eu envie d'en faire sur
moi étaient que l'on s'y fait faire sur
moi j'ai eu envie d'attraper la machine
pour en faire moi-même et tellement une
évidence que c'est ce que j'allais faire
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours puisque je
suis jamais vraiment posé la question
effectivement je fais ça depuis quelques
années donc ça c'est presque 30 ans que
je fais ça fait quelques années à
l'époque quand j'ai commencé c'était
plus des voyous des rockers ce qu'ils
veulent est un tueur qui m'empêchait pas
de l'être à l'époque mais comme j'ai pas
été formés ni apprenti chez un tatoueur
donc jeux hentai les
libraire l'ailé bookshop pour pour
trouver de l'inspiration et des modèles
et comme dans toute histoire de l'art on
s'inspire de ce qui a été fait
auparavant et donc moi j'ai commencé à
faire du tatouage et dvd but je me suis
mis sans aucune peur telle bien
naïvement mais enfin c'est ce qui m'a
démarquer des autres tout de suite je
faisais des portraits j'ai reproduit lui
michel-ange du raphaël des pin up et
après voilà j'ai peut-être mis en place
un style qui a été moult fois pour pas
dire qu'au pied mais qui a inspiré
d'autres tatoueur donc c'est peut-être
pour ça que je suis un type connu ça
c'est un plan borzage et puisqu'il ya
certains bourgeois qui se sont
appropriés mais ce ne veut pas dire
qu'il a quitté les rangs des punks et
et autres personnages de gang
donc voilà il ya plein de bande qui soit
encore tatoué mais il ya aussi les
chanteurs les avocats les hommes
politiques les les couturières donc ça
ça appartient à tout le monde comme
voilà chez le boulanger il ya le flic et
voyou il achète tous les deux leur poids
si je vous dis simplement bob sinclar
votre rythme cardiaque s'accélère vos
jambes ont la bougeotte vous avez envie
de danser de chanter c'est bien normal
le dj français enflamme les dancefloors
du monde entier depuis maintenant
plusieurs années entre deux mixes et
deux avions nous sommes allés à sa
rencontre c'est l'incontournable de ce
culture tu es sans frontières
[Musique]
oh
non
et
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bienvenue en culture t
merci m'accueillir dans ce lieu qui est
un lieu de perdition en entendant
créativité je me suis perdu la vie ici
je n ya pas de ya pas de fenêtre en fait
on a pas de notion de temps donc c'est
vrai qu'on peut rester les jours entiers
ici sans s'apercevoir donc que ce soit
mais si tu as tu as ta 35000 vinyle
autour de toi et c'est un peu mon mon
repère de création qu'est ce qu'il reste
du petit gamin qui en 1978
quelle chance est allé faire
l'inauguration de la coupe du monde en
argentine c'est pas mal ça c'est vrai
qu'elles sont au courant de ça c'est
fabuleux j'avais on a été sélectionné
par la mairie de paris à l'époque
j'étais en poussins et on était donc 7,7
petit petit garçon en avait 9 ans à
partir en argentine pour la coupe du
monde et on est parti rejoindre raymond
kopa pierre cangioni et puis toute
l'équipe de france avec michel platini
avait gérard janvion jean paul bertrand
demanes olivier rouyer toute cette super
super équipe de l'époque
moi j'étais un fou de football et j'ai
toujours été un fou de sport en général
mais c'était prédestiné finalement tu
étais prêt pour voyager avait traversé
l'italie
oui j'ai été je voulais sportifs
professionnels évidemment à 9 ans tu as
la musique tu prends pas encore mais
c'était joue les de football a rejeté un
peu petit physiquement j'étais un peu
faible ensuite je me suis mis au tennis
il ya beaucoup d'ailleurs de tennisman
vous voulez doute footballeur avant où
j'ai passé des sports
quand on est jeune on aime bien ces deux
sports là et donc je voulais faire ça ou
sommes voilà je vais pas le talent ont
commencé à 16 17 ans d'un coup j'ai
écouté radio nova dynastie et d'un coup
sa matrice ham a révolutionné
je te rappelle des premiers vinyles non
pas que tu écoutais que tu as acheté
mais quittons servi a commencé à faire
du mix à retravailler de la musique au
départ au départ moi enfin mon processus
est et j'ai vu un dj j'étais je
commençais à sortir dans les clubs vers
17 ans 18 au palace donc voila c'était
l'arrivée du rap
il y avait en même temps de la hausse
aussi donc les dj passé un peu tout et
il y avait cette technique de mix la
musique était très dynamique et puis je
sais pas ça m'a ça a complètement
révolutionné mon esprit que je te dis
j'écoutais dynastie ces techniques de ce
crash le rap français aussi arriver au
même moment où les bmtn assassins tous a
bon voilà c'est de ça faisait des
mixtapes et une espèce de révolution
artistique comme ça en france et je peux
pas dire que je me suis pas dit un jour
je vais faire des mix nous soutient je
vais j'aime bien ce sont là avant ça
existe convient bon bah je vais acheter
un vinyle ensuite de vinyle trois vies
mintya pourquoi pas je vais demander à
noël des platines et puis je me faisais
mes cassettes pour mes propres cassettes
pour aller à l'école il n'y avait aucun
exemple enfin n'y avait rien qui pouvait
me dire qu'il y avait une espèce de
lueur pour faire une carrière ou quoi
que ce soit la honte je parle des tout
débuts qui petit à petit ensuite j'ai
voulu faire partager ma musique donc
jouer devant des gens ils pourquoi pas
créer cette musique on j'ai acheté un
sampler qu'il ya un processus assez long
dans tout ça quatre ou cinq ans et ça a
été assez rapide mais je me suis
passionné par ce sont là parfois il ya
des journées où des rencontres qui
marquent notre vie on se dit voilà
finalement la lueur je n'ai eu là à ce
moment là je me suis dit bah finalement
oui je suis c'est ma destinée faut que
j'aille là dedans tu te souviens de sa
toi j'ai pas eu un moment où je suis la
lueur mais c'est surtout de la musique
mama prêt physiquement
merci je la ressens physiquement c c'est
une émotion assez difficile à exprimer
avec un vrai lien comme le sportif que
tu exactement exactement exactement il y
avait 700 c'est ce frisson que tu as
quand tu quand tu quand tu écoute de la
musique ou quand tu joues tu m'as tu
marques un beau point un joli but
elle sait tout ça est très artistique
mais je ne peux pas te dire pourquoi
cette musique m'a choisie en fait et ça
me donnait tellement de bonheur que je
ne pouvais pas faire autre chose quand
j'ai dit à ma mère j'ai eu un bon bac
j'ai fait un bac + 2
quand je lui ai dit écoute
c'est ça que je veux faire je peux rien
faire d'autre cestjoelle je veux créer
des sons je vais essayer d'en faire mon
métier je sais pas où je vais mais je
veux le faire lorsque tu fais danser les
dizaines au début aujourd'hui des
milliers de personnes du pur live qu'est
les sentiments ses patins de sentiments
j'ai pas de grandeur absolut et non non
c'est toi aussi mais quand même c'est
l'extraordinaire l'adrénaline pure
adrénaline
c'est la même chose que quinze sportifs
encore une fois quand tu maîtrises ton
art que ce soit le tennis ou de football
hectares à d jean valade et mis des gens
qui te regardent ou est transcendé par
le par l'énergie qui se passe dans ce
stade c'est exactement la même chose moi
je vais je connais mon métier
parfaitement
je connais mes disques sur le bout des
doigts et à la mesure presse et vendent
entre ces traits tout est très calculé
c'est presqu'une une partition
évidemment il ya un peu d'improvisation
en fonction des gens que tu as devant
toi si tu vas y dis ça il a battu pour
être beaucoup plus pointu que si tu
joues dans le centre de la france où les
gens s'attendent à voir que des tubes
mais c'est une émotion une un partage
d'énergie une communication
je pense ne peut être que comprise que
par un chanteur ou un musicien c'est je
pense que c'est la même sensation c'est
à dire que par moment tu sais qu'à cette
presque 7 secondes là tu vas enflammé
tout bien sûr évidemment à ce que toutes
mes énergies
donc là où tu reconnais un bon dj c'est
quand il joue avec l'énergie des gens tu
peux pas jouer une énergie de bonne
heure du début jusqu'à la fin de concept
c'est à dire l'énergie de bonheur qui
est générée par un tube sur tube que les
gens connaissent donc ces voix là c'est
la joie
donc il faut que tu passes par des
moments d'ennui des moments presque
d'agde et de cannes très agressive des
moments de guerre moment de méchanceté
revenir sur ce moment de bonheur qui ne
peut être que
sur trois heures que peut être six ou
sept fois
mais c'est cette énergie ou peut-être
faut choisir ses moments stratégiques au
début au milieu à la fin ça pour laisser
un toujours l'impact du début le milieu
pour passion faire qu'ils s'en aillent
ensuite la fin pour dire ah ben voilà on
a passé une soirée incroyable mais tout
ça se gère d'accord alors par ace by
night parisienne musicale expérience
c'est la nouvelle création qu'est ce
qu'on va trouver qu'est ce qui a changé
par rapport aux dernières créations un
concept totalement burlesques je vois là
que j'ai imaginé comme ça c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui de créer un album
il ya si tu as de la chance par atik qui
passe en radio et les onze type qui
reste passe à la trappe
donc ce que j'ai aimé donc sur ce sur ce
projet c'était de travailler un petit
peu comme je le faisais sur africanisme
au début des années 2000 partir sans
pression sans avoir un objectif
commercial juste orienté sur le dj et
sur des sonorités nouvelles je passe de
deux images sous mac qui est une artiste
péruvienne une chanteuse complètement
emparé mambo alors totalement remix et
bien sûr à jesse garonne qui avaient
fait un morceau rockabilly à l'époque
mais totalement retransformer un morceau
sur leur mode là qui est hyper espère
inspirer qualif musique californienne
avec des sons d'aujourd'hui
voilà j'ai pris des sonorités cabaret
burlesque très parisienne avec charlie
chaplin que j'ai voyagé j'ai remis au
goût du jour et j'ai fait une
association avec vente privee.com qui
m'a permis de me dire voilà tu fais un
album pointus comme tu le sens et ça
passe et on va proposer ce à un moment
[Musique]
tu comprends mieux aujourd'hui je
reviens pas sur l' aventure de 1978 en
argentine
mais pourquoi tu es devenu international
c'est difficilement explicable en fait
le fait que je fais des chansons en
anglais peut-être ce qui est fabuleux
c'est dans mon parcours c'est que les dj
qui qui qui sont là sur cette scène
aujourd'hui sont devenus des artistes
jeudi a lieu ce qu'aia genre 95 j'en
parle même pas il n'y avait même pas de
le statut dj n'était pas reconnue sur
les sociétés d'auteurs et de
compositeurs aujourd'hui un simple dj
peut toucher des droits
aujourd'hui il est son propre manager
son propre producteur il peut créer sa
musique tout seul dans sa chambre
la distribuer et faire son propre clip
lemaitre le faire partager sur ces
réseaux sociaux
tu n'as plus besoin d'une maison de
disques aujourd'hui d'un même d'un petit
label pour pouvoir exister ça c'est
fabienne création ce qui est génial
donc ça j'en suis assez fier parce que
finalement je suis pas le seul mais je
dirais quand même je fais partie d'une
certaine locomotive pour pour tous ces
jeunes
et puis il ya encore dix ans un
journaliste alors patois bien sûr mais
un journaliste aurait dit alors sinclar
les rêves la techno la drogue par mois
pinton d'expérience qu'est ce que t'as
frieling frais avec la crise et ça c'est
bon c'est la passion musicale moi j'ai
toujours pour ça que j'ai toujours dans
le sport beaucoup ou je fais des
associations avec roland garros ont fait
la journée des enfants voilà j'essaie
toujours de mélanger beaucoup de tennis
avec la avec ma musique
qu'est ce que ça fait d'être finalement
totalement libre aujourd'hui ça c'est un
bonheur c'est un privilège
parce que j'ai commencé avec un tout
petit budget petit à petit j'ai fabriqué
mais 10 g touré investi dans mon bain
dans la prod pour pouvoir produire
d'autres artistes
et puis faire mes propres clips voilà je
suis vraiment 100% indépendant
je me suis associé à des majors pour
pouvoir avoir une distribution de plus
grande envergure sur ma musique mais
j'ai adoré toutes ces années et je pense
qu'on peut on peut revenir aujourd'hui à
des modèles plus indépendants comme
comme le circuit d'une solution que je
fais avec ce nouvel album
non non je suis je suis vraiment
passionné toujours j'ai pu a toujours un
milliard de choses à dire en produits
plein de jeunes encore plein de jeunes
dj eric boulton mis quelques allemands
ils sont deux jeunes que j'ai signé
récemment voilà j'essaie de trouver de
nouvelles façons de les promouvoir de
créer leur image
distribuer la musique merci mais je
parle beaucoup
on reste dans le domaine musical avec
une rencontre exceptionnelle en
compagnie du harpiste xavier de maistre
l'app store
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout a commencé par un coup de foudre
c'est encore jeune élève du
conservatoire de toulon que xavier de
maistre découvre l'art mais difficile de
savoir si à l'époque c'est de
l'instrument ou plutôt de sa professeure
donc j'invite mme banon il y avait un
festival au revest en plein air où les
instruments étaient présentés dont quand
il y avait un duo flûte et harpe et
c'est la clé pour la première fois j'ai
vu j'ai vu cet instrument et qui était
jouée en fait part à aussi par va ma
prof de solfège de l'époque et c'était
quelqu'un que j'aimais beaucoup
et là j'ai décidé que je voulais
vraiment commencé l'instrument quelques
à l'enseigné dans c'est un coup de
foudre à la fois pour l'instrument et
pour le professeur monde autres
références et harpo marx que j'ai
vraiment qui était quelqu'un que
j'admirais beaucoup
après c'est un univers sonore parce que
je trouve qu'il ya vraiment tout un tout
un dessert des couleurs qu'on ne peut qu
on ne peut avoir que sur cet instrument
alors c'est vrai que le répertoire n'est
pas le plus riche mais il ya une
possibilité d'emmener les gens vraiment
dans un univers très très spécial
[Musique]
une vocation qui n'emballe pas plus que
ça son entourage car si les deux
monstres comptent parmi leurs aïeux
l'une de nos plumes les plus auguste pas
l'ombre d'un musicien en revanche dans
l'album de famille marc b lyon c'était
justement de vouloir devenir parce que
dans ma famille s'il n'y avait jamais eu
le musicien donc j'ai fait aussi on m'a
obligé à faire des études classiques
donc je suis allé à sciences po à paris
après la noce comique à londres et mick
toujours d'air en arrière tâche me
disais si j'ai la possibilité c'est la
voie que souhaiterait emprunter après
c'est évident qu'on doute parce qu'il
faut savoir que c'est un instrument où
les débouchés sont très très rares
une si on pense aux orchestres au
maximum une place par orchestre donc en
europe il faut compter deux voire trois
places par an total pour tous il ya
beaucoup plus de harpistes qu'on ne
compte qu on pense
la harpe l'instrument de prédilection
d'apollon le dieu du soleil d'orphée le
mythique musiciens ou encore de la reine
marie antoinette un instrument réputé
limité dans son répertoire un instrument
de salon peut-être un peu désuet donc
aviez de maistre décide de s'emparer ses
doigts en révèle le potentiel le
réinvente le dynamise une virtuosité qui
l'amène à devenir à 24 ans seulement le
premier instrumentistes français à être
admis dans l' orchestre philharmonique
de vienne
il en élargit le répertoire a même
l'ardent territoire inconnu
en transposant l'instrument dans des
oeuvres majeures celle de mozart haydn
ou de debussy pour ne citer qu'eux
n'ayant pas suffisamment de répertoire
je suis obligé de créer mon propre
répertoire donc de susciter des
commandes d'arranger des pièces soit
pour écrire au départ pour le piano ou
pour le violon et de l'est et de les
proposer sur mon instrument et c'est
quelque chose de très novateur et qui
m'amuse beaucoup
ce côté créatif c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement existence quand vous êtes
pianistes violonistes et vous
enregistrer un disque ça a été en tout
les oeuvres que vous allez faire ont
déjà été gravées par les plus grands des
dizaines voire des centaines de fois
alors qu'au moins les projets que je
fais la plupart de temps ce sont des
créations sont des choses novatrices
comme les j'avais repris là l'hiver des
quatre saisons
ou bien le concerto pour piano de mozart
que j'enregistrais semaine prochaine
a salzbourg et c'est vrai que maintenant
j'ai une maison de disques victime qui
me donne un peu carte blanche ce qu'ils
ont vu que keith le public devenait de
plus en plus j'avais plus en plus de
gens qui s'intéressait à ce que à ce que
je faisais et cathy qui étaient devenus
curieux et ça c'est c'est une grande
chance
désormais xavier de maistre s'affranchit
de l' orchestre c'est le premier artiste
au monde à se produire en soliste déjà
trois albums sortis chez sony ou en solo
xavier de maistre continue de casser les
clichés pour donner à l'arpp une
nouvelle image entre musicalité et des
gans et tempérament
on est sur les toits de paris mais
j'entends encore les mélodies un qui
sort de l'arbre de xavier de metz
c'était vraiment un très très beau
moment on n'a pas fini toutes les
rencontres de cette émission je vous
emmène maintenant à rouen et à tahiti 80
tahiti 80 c'est le nom du groupe
tous les membres sont originaires de la
ville de rouen mais leur succès ils
l'ont bâti l'on construit à non pas en
france mais à l'étranger au japon en
amérique du nord en amérique du sud
heureusement pour nous ils reviennent de
temps en temps en france soit un concert
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
c'était à la cigale en surf l'aude score
[Musique]
et
et dire que tout ça a démarré en
normandie sur un 4 pistes il y a vingt
ans vingt ans que la petite troupe de
tahiti 80 égrène sa french pop à travers
le monde
20 ans est toujours la même énergie la
même humilité et la même honnêteté
difficile pourtant de classe et leur son
est pourquoi essayer après tout ses cinq
albums plus tard il expérimente encore
s'il influence de la pop des années 60
et de la salle de la montagne sont très
identifiable le résultat lui il est un
peu moins on écrivait des chansons comme
ça et j'ai l'impression que ça par le
sap a finalement énormément changé c'est
le rapport à la musique qu'on avait à
l'époque c'est à dire de d'essayer de de
créer quelque chose de décès de
retranscrire voilà cette chanson pop
parfaite qu'on avait dans la tête j'ai
l'impression qu'on court toujours après
et on est il ya toujours la même
excitation apprécierait que les
instruments ont changé maintenant on est
passé le k de piste où on a un studio à
rouen qui est où on enregistre tous nos
albums on est un studio professionnel
donc oui il ya eu voilà des quelques
des améliorations comme ça il ya eu une
remise en cause continuelle avec chaque
album de se dire ça on l'a déjà fait on
a déjà exploré ce truc là qu'est ce
qu'on qu'est ce qu'on pourrait s que là
par exemple j'ai pas fait un peu le tour
de la guitare sur cet album est ce que
je pourrais essayer de composer au piano
ou est-ce que là ce sera le moment pour
apprendre à programmer des boîtes à
rythmes sur deux choses donc il ya
toujours eu on va dire une nouveauté
dans chaque dans chaque cycle qui fait
que finalement voilà on a toujours un
peu la chance du débutant sur ce genre
de chose d'un album à l'autre les
accents se font plus groove davantage
destiné au dancefloor comme sur leur
album fosbury parfois plus pop folk
synthétique un peu new wave bref on ne
se refuse rien comme une recherche voilà
des essayé d'incorporer parfois des
éléments de métis est peut-être un peu
notre pop music ont annoncé à eux on a
toujours adoré la musique dite noire la
soul aussi le d'oeuvre la musique
électronique donc on retrouve un peu
tous ces éléments qui ce qui se dit lui
on espère de justement de façon assez
harmonieuse nous français en jouant avec
des codes anglo saxons
anglais américains voire même parfois un
peu suédois parce qu'on aimait bien
aussi la musique suédoise résultats en
fait en prenant un petit peu de chaque
scène on a on a
créer un son un peu différent et c'est
vrai qu'avec peut-être aussi la
sensibilité française sans le savoir
qu'on participe et peut-être à
l'écriture comme ça d'une esthétique
voilà maintenant c'est vrai qu'on parle
de french pop ou alors que je pense
qu'il ya quelques années ça faisait
peut-être un peu c'était plutôt
moqueries qu'autre chose sûre de nexon
isi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en vingt ans de carrière tahiti 80 a
conquis un public international
d'ailleurs plus international que
français cas allez comprendre
'nos hip hop troubadours sont boudés
dans l'hexagone leur pays d'origine
trop pop pas assez rock un peu électro
alors leur succès s'est construit
ailleurs avant tout au japon dès leurs
débuts avant les états unis et enfin
l'europe qu'on n'est pas on est assez
insaisissable finalement parce qu un
côté en fin d'album qui met plus un rôle
et après on revient avec un album rock
mais on revient après avec un album un
peu électro et peut-être que ça c'est
difficile de se faire finalement
un peu on est peut être catalogué comme
justement comme si finalement pendant ce
temps ceux autres il ya les gars rock
pop sol et nous on est dans l'autre
catégorie qui n'existe pas qui n'a pas
de nom
le fait justement que par exemple il ya
des degrés divers aussi que c'est aux
états unis on est un succès mais que ça
reste on va dire indépendant par contre
au japon que ce soit un peu plus gros
que soi plus mainstream par exemple
c'est vrai que ça permet aussi de et en
france où on a on a des fans mais ça
reste un peu fait pas marginal entre les
deux quoi donc ça permet un peu de
relativiser
disons le franchement les français ne
savent pas ce qu'ils ratent
mais le groupe n'en tire aucune amertume
la créativité est toujours là surtout
qu'ils ont désormais leur propre label
personne ne viendra plus les brimer
tahiti 80 peut désormais penser aux
vingt prochaines années
très sereinement c'est fou parce que je
j'ai pensé à quelques jours et je me
suis dit waouh qu'est ce qu'on va faire
et je repensais justement ces
enregistrements qu'on avait fait à
l'époque peut-être que ce serait parce
qu'il ya des chansons qui sont pas
sortis il serait assez rigolo finalement
de soin de les ressortir soit peut-être
aussi de bas de l'échelle et finir une
bonne fois pour toute et de sortir ce
petit truc est de 2
de l'offrir aux gens peut-être ce serait
bien
[Musique]
c'est désormais votre instant
politicards politique assez simple une
femme un homme politique face à une
oeuvre d'art cette semaine nous sommes
allés à la rencontre d'esther benbassa
la sénatrice europe ecologie les verts
qui a choisi comme oeuvres d'art
l'exposition chagall
[Musique]
cette peinture au dessus de vie qu est
ce qu il a été peint en 1915 1920 et
c'est l'époque de son retour de france
d'ailleurs on voit très bien
l'influencent cubiste dans cette
peinture
et puis l'homme qui est là le personnage
qui est dans les airs c'est le fameux
blue stream heintz l'homme désert à
hyéres n'est ce pas et qui est pauvre
qui n'a pas un métier sur qui vit au
jour le jour c'est le colporteur qui va
de village en village vous voyez il a un
baluchon il vend de la marchandise des
vêtements des objets pour la cuisine etc
et il devient le vendredi dans son
village pour être avec sa famille et
faire les prières juives à la la
synagogue avec ses amis et là vous avez
ce personnage qui aussi l'exil est
l'homme des ailes c'est aussi l'homme
qui n'a pas d'attaché qui n'a pas de
racines c'est un peu chagall lui même
qui est revenu de france qui ne sait pas
choisir encore il est exilé en russie
dans son propre village exil est de
france où il a connu des peintres où il
a fréquenté les milieux artistiques où
il se laisse influencer pour sa peinture
alors là c'est aussi toute cette vie
un peu un peu enfermé c'est la neige
c'est un climat rude
vous voyez les arbres sont enneigées
tout est à neiger et il y a quand même
ce côté rieurs de chagall
ben oui c'est l'artiste c'est la poésie
de chagall et c'est une très belle
exposition j'espère que nombreux seront
ceux qui viendront goûter un au plaisir
de la poésie de la peinture poétique
[Musique]
c'est la fin de votre émission à culture
telle émission sans frontières consacré
à ces artistes français connus et
reconnus a dans le monde entier c'est
évidemment une première étape je vous
proposerai d'autres émissions de ce type
pour vous présenter ces artistes qui
brille dans le monde entier au delà nos
frontières et qui en vain enfin peut
briller la france sa culture française
comme cet hôtel le bristol connu et
apprécié lui aussi dans le monde entier
sur né à remercier toutes ces équipes de
nous avoir accueillis ici nous avoir
permis de tourner l'émission dans des
lieux rare et exceptionnel juste avant
de nous quitter un petit peu de lecture
pour vous présenter des ouvrages qui est
pour moi représente un petit peu le côté
hétéroclite de votre émission tous ces
artistes que j'aime vous proposer à
chaque numéro de culture t pour
commencer à la véritable histoire de
spirent aux éditions dupuis s'est
évidemment l'histoire du groom le plus
célèbre de la bande dessinée je sais pas
s'il à l'entrée du bristol en tout cas
on le retrouve dans cet ouvrage
voilà toute son histoire sa naissance et
son succès toujours d'actualité
aujourd'hui
street art aux éditions place des
victoires très bel ouvrage qui nous a
montré une nouvelle fois s'il fallait le
démontrer que les graffeurs en france et
à l'étranger sont des artistes à part
entière
mille et une couverture paris match aux
éditions vela c'est tout simplement les
plus belles couvertures depuis 1949
redécouvrir ce magazine à travers ses
stars ses reportages mail une couverture
c'est l'occasion de re découvrir ce
qu'est paris match aussi dans l'histoire
des français tatouage colorés vous avez
découvert le travail de tintin au début
de l'émission c'est tatoueur france est
connue en france mais aussi à l'étranger
vous allez découvrir des tatouages très
diverses couleurs noir et blanc surtout
des design assez incroyable enfin don
quichotte aux éditions diane de selliers
c'est l'occasion de re découvrir ce
grand classique de la littérature
illustrée par l'un des peintres les plus
reconnus mondialement aujourd'hui gérard
garouste merci de nous avoir suivi
toutes les infos évidemment c'est sur
mon profil facebook tous les jeudis
matin ma chronique coup de coeur bd dans
le quotidien métro ciao et à bientôt
pour d'autres aventures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
k
[Musique]
en chine les ouvriers sortent de l'ombre
dans les ateliers
ils se mobilisent pour l'arrco